Pete Davidson officially moved on from
Kim K and right into the arms of model
Emily radakowski family
house Pete's birthday
oh it's on just one day after E.T
confirmed things have become flirtatious
between the friends who are now enjoying
dating the magic match pair got into PDA
for Pete's 29th birthday and you know
the paparazzi were all about getting the
money shot look at Emily 8 10 p.m that's
Pete's Mini Cooper speeding off after
camera spooked him outside the model's
West Village Apartment Emily was left at
the curb for 30 minutes until we're told
and Uber took her to meet Pete in
Brooklyn didn't spend the night she was
back home at 12 49 a.m she knows how to
like make someone feel really good about
themselves last night vs and L Alum also
made his debut on the Kardashians
revealing how Kim actually turned him
down a month before they started dating
you guys asked for a number at the last
minute and you pretended that you
couldn't give it to me because you had
gloves on women find him very attractive
yeah well obviously yep everyone from
Martha Stewart to Ariana Grande agrees
so just when did Pete in the model from
the Blurred Lines music video video
Start hook it up we're not exactly sure
but they do have history posing for this
Fantastical photo shoot in September of
2021. guys are like wow what's that guy
got and I'm like I mean he seems super
Charming yeah vulnerable he's lovely
great his fingernail polish is awesome
like he looks good we're told both have
actually known each other for a while
because they run in similar circles can
you elaborate on it for us sure he's
actually buddy buddy with her ex-husband
producer Sebastian bear mclard they've
hit up basketball games and worked
together on the film bodies bodies
bodies we're having fun
[Music]
thank you